because of his beautiful rainbow colored
eyes and pure white hair domo is seen as
a supernatural being since birth and is
groomed into the religious leader of the
paradise faith cult a position he
maintains to the present day when he was
still a child his mother had a mental
breakdown and stabbed his father to
death for having numerous affairs with
other female cult disciples she
committed suicide immediately afterwards
by poisoning herself to death however
despite these series of grueling events
happening right in front of him doma
only felt annoyed by the bloody mess
created in the aftermath and was
disgusted by the pungent smell of blood
he simply wanted to air out the room
before the stench permanently stuck to
the furniture at 20 years old he met
muzan kibutsuji who transformed him into
a demon at some point domo became the
upper rank 6 of the 12 kazuki during
that time while he was roaming around
the entertainment district and feasting
off the flash of the geishas and other
young maidens he stumbled across the
siblings gyotaro and daki who were both
at death's door gyotaro had been stabbed
in the back and was slowly bleeding to
death while his sister daki had been
burnt to the point of being
unrecognizable being a nice guy dome
offered to turn the pair into demons and
save them proceeding to give them his
blood to initiate their transformation
he challenges them to become powerful
enough to be recognized by that man and
to become an upper rank in the 12 kazuki
at some point domwo became upper rank 2
surpassing upper rank 3 akaza despite
becoming a demon more recently than him
15 years prior to the present dome had a
brief history with enosuke hashibira his
mother kotoha
escaped from her abusive household with
his father and found a refuge in the
paradise faith cult although doma
considered katoha stupid her beauty and
singing talent convinced stoma not to
consume her and simply let her live her
life however she discovered he is
devouring other followers and fled from
the temple with enosuke in her arms
before she could be killed she dropped
enosuke off a cliff into a river in
hopes he would survive doma shortly
caught up with them and proceeded to
swiftly kill her and makinosuke for his
fate before eating kotoha to the very
bones a few years before the present he
encountered and fought kane kocho he
mortally wounded her but was forced to
retreat from the rising sun before he
could devour her
at the gathering of the upper ranks doma
questions akus's lack of concern for him
placing a hand on his colleague's
shoulder he expresses his worry for his
comrade safety before engaging gyoko and
small talk about his spots and to the
one that he had been given an irritated
akuza tells doma to move his hand
punching him when he didn't immediately
comply regenerating the damage almost
instantly doma complements his fellow
upper rank wondering if he had gotten
stronger since the last meeting soon
after muzan arrived and upper rank 2
listened as his leader reported
gyotaro's death doma apologizes being
the one who has introduced him to the 12
kazuki he claims responsibility for his
failure and eagerly wonders what kind of
punishment muzan would inflict on him
but is instead told that nothing is
expected of him the eccentric doma
questions this but muzan pointed out the
continued existence of the ubiashiki
family and the failure to find the blue
spider lily causes noma to concede that
he isn't the best at detective work he
later approached gyoko eager to
accompany him on his new mission but
said the top half of his head destroyed
by akuza for not following their
leader's orders doma swiftly regenerates
from this and attempts to play kate
kokushibo who had cut off akus's hand
for disrupting the hierarchy hearing
that it hadn't been for his benefit doma
noted that kokoshiba's suggestion that
akusa should apply for a bloody battle
would be a waste of time given their
difference in strength and that he
hadn't dodged akus's blow on purpose he
then cheerfully bid kokoshibo goodbye
again attempting to engage akuza in
conversation and once more tried to join
gyoko and hantengu on their mission
failing on both accounts he attempts to
flirt with nakime only to be rejected
and transported back to his master room
in the paradise faith cult upon being
told that his followers had arrived doma
quickly put on a ceremonial hat and
instructs the messenger to bring them in
[Music]
as he is consuming a group of his female
disciples inside nakime's infinity
castle doma notices shinobu at the
entrance to his room he reacts with
delight as having another meal walk
right into his room one of his disciples
still alive beg shinobu to save her and
doma irritated by this attempts to
finish her off only for shinobu to jump
in and save her she asks the young woman
if she is all right but before she can
answer shinobu's question the young
woman explodes and dies right in front
of her eyes angered by this and doma's
insistence that he saved the girl by
killing her shinobu notices a pair of
sharp fans that douma uses as his main
weapon and angrily inquires if he
remembers the heyori that originally
belonged to her elder sister doma
finally remembers her by the butterfly
wing design heyori that kane once wore
it playfully expresses his
disappointment at not being able to eat
kane due to the sun rising further
angering shinobu the insect teshira
swiftly launches an attack at him using
her to inflict a powerful stab directly
into doma's right eyeball which
impresses him since he couldn't block it
he correctly guesses that she lacks the
physical strength to cut off a demon's
head and becomes excited upon learning
that chenobu's true strength lies in her
use of various poisons to kill her
opponents shinobu initially hoped that
the first dosage of poison she injected
into him would be effective enough to
kill him but then learns much to her
disappointment that doma had already
received information regarding her
poison from her battle against the
spider family of lower rank 5. doma then
manages to break down and render her
poison non-lethal healing himself from
her attack she is further backed into a
corner due to doma's rapid development
of antibodies after a mere five slashes
and injections of poison he is not
resistant to it entirely also due to his
blood demon art of frozen mist the air
around the room they are fighting in is
growing gradually colder causing it to
become increasingly difficult for
shinobu to breathe hedging her bets on
one last attack shinobu strikes using
insect breathing dance of the dragonfly
and successfully hits him however as she
strikes he simultaneously strikes her
cutting both her collarbone and ribs
puncturing one of her lungs
shinobu in a near-death state almost
losing every hope in victory attempts to
draw strength from replaying her older
sister's words of encouragement in her
head shinobu then prepares to strike at
doma again despite her serious injuries
in the immense pain she is in and
attacks him again using insect breathing
dance of the centipede she strikes doma
directly through his neck impaling him
and sending him flying towards the
ceiling exhausted and wounded shinobu is
relieved upon seeing doma poisoned and
seemingly dying from her attack however
domo recovers almost instantly by which
shinobu is further enraged now exhausted
fatally injured and dangerously near
death shinobu was caught by doma as they
were falling down from the ceiling he
embraces her in a bear hug and begins
mocking her for calling her entire
attempt to defeat him a waste of effort
assuring her she will live peacefully as
a part of him and mockingly asking her
for her last words she spitefully curses
him as he begins to kill her domo breaks
shinobu's body in his arms and begins to
absorb her just as her disciple
kaneosuri arrives at the scene but just
before her death she manages to send a
mysterious signal to her successor with
her hand her death causes kaneo to go
berserk in order to try to save her only
to be repelled by an irritated doma who
tells her not to interfere when he's in
the middle of absorbing someone he
successfully devours shinobu's body
until her butterfly shaped hairpiece is
the only thing left of her
doma notes aloud that kaneo must have
been told something by the signal
shinobu gave her shortly before her
death wondering what it could be as
kaneo stands silently before him enraged
as he licks shinobu's airplane he says
that it is a good night as such fine
meals keep showing up one after another
after akus's death doma says that he
felt as if the upper rank had turned
into a different creature before he died
and that his demise was inevitable
because he never ate any women domo
begins to cry over his best friend's
death but kaneo just tells him to stop
with the lies she explains that she
knows every word that comes out of his
mouth is nothing but random babble and
that it's impossible for him to be
genuinely sad over akaza because he
can't feel anything at all she says that
every person born into the world has
feelings but doma cannot understand
these feelings and covers them up by
spitting lies he has never felt
happiness joy pain and bitterness he is
nothing but an empty shell she also
asked doma why he was even born doma's
face turned serious and he asked how
kaneo can say something so cruel to
which the young demon slayer responds
that she simply hates him and wants to
send him to hell this instant suddenly
doma appears behind kaneo attempting to
use one of his fans to cut her head off
but she quickly dodges and delivers a
blow to his stomach causing some of his
organs to fall out he doesn't seem to
feel or blow simply sending some of his
ice lotuses at her and denoting that her
reaction speed has increased as she's
able to adapt to his attacks as he
regenerates his body he thinks to
himself that kaneo could actually be
stronger than shinobu a hashira trying
to suppress her rage kanyo attacks domo
with her flower breathing which he
avoids with ease smiling and commenting
on how pretty her attack is before
launching his blood demon art at her
which she barely fends off doma notices
that the main reason why she is able to
counter and dodge his attacks is because
of her immensely keen eyesight kanye
herself is able to easily predict and
guess his every move due to taking note
of the subtle movements of his shoulders
gaze toes elbows and knees having
figured out the reason for her reflexes
and reactions doma decides that the best
course of action would be to simply take
her eyes out with the swing of his fans
however kanye successfully dodges his
attack and charges at him with flower
breathing which is nullified by doma's
blood demon art the upper rank sends two
more attacks lotus vines and cold white
princesses which he only just avoids
before its wintry icicles begin to rain
on her from above kaneo dodges again
moving further away from the demon who
laughs at her and says that she can't
keep moving backward if she wants to cut
his head off quicker than the blink of
an eye domo runs at kaneo and snatches
her blade returning and planting it into
the ground a distance away from her he
says that she better come and get it
quickly if she wants to continue
fighting him before sending his blood
demon arc at the demon slayer
at that moment inosuke breaks through
the ceiling of the room protecting kaneo
from doma's attack with his beast
breathing he looks at doma's eyes and
notices that he's the upper rank too
happily shouting that if he beats the
demon he'll become a hashira and asking
kanye what his hashira title should be
inosuki notices kanyo's beaten up face
and asks surprised what had happened
saying that chenoble will get mad if she
finds her sukuko in that state kaneo
remains silent and the warheaded demon
slayer asks if shinobu is dead to which
doma replies that she isn't she will
live inside him for all eternity because
he has saved her from her pain and
suffering and escape recall shinobi's
kindness towards him and vows to doma
that he'll kill him as he rushes towards
the upper rank with his beast breathing
kanye shouts out warning him not to
breathe in doma's cold air as the demon
remarks at how messed up his technique
is doma attempts to slice off endoski's
head with one of his fans but the demon
slayer dodges launching himself from the
flat edge of the fan and landing next to
kaneo he hands kaneo her blade which he
had taken back from doma and tells her
to never let go of it again doma smiles
and compliments inosuki's speed as he
jumps towards him and the two engage in
quick combat launching breathing styles
and blood demon arts at each other at
alarming rates anosuke kicks doma in the
stomach sending him skidding backwards
as he dislocates the joints in his right
arm and prepares to swing a sword at the
upper rank's neck he misjudges his swing
and instead slices through doma's eye
with his beast breathing while the demon
laughs at his unusual technique doma
calls hinosuke messed up and says that
he's never met a kid like him before
despite his long life spam to which the
demon slayer replies that that's obvious
since he's the great inosuke at an
incredible speed doma runs forward and
snatches the mask from his head as he's
speaking and donosuke enraged tells him
to give it back the demon slayer notices
his face and says that he remembers a
nosuke from somewhere asking him if
they'd met before inosuke responds that
they hadn't as he would remember meeting
someone like doma but the upper rank
insists that they have proceeding to
stick his fingers through his skull and
into his brain to try and jog his
memories doma says that he knew
inosuke's mother as his cult took her in
but inosuke denies that he is a mother
since he was raised by boars doma laughs
and says that he must have a human
mother since he's a human and sinowski
shouts at him to quit spouting lies and
give him back his boar mask rushing in
to attack the demon again with his beast
breathing his torso is flashed twice by
doma's fans who smiles shyly and tells
him not to interrupt him before sending
him back flying to kaneo with the zeiss
doma then tells the story of katoha
inosuke's mother memories of her begin
to come back to inosuke who recalls the
song she used to sing to him doma calls
katoha stupid and unfortunate saying
that there isn't a happy moment in her
life and donoski now enraged thanks doma
for allowing him to remember this story
and promises not only to kill him for
what he did to katoha and shinobu but to
put him through hell beforehand doma
smiles again and tells inosuke that
there is no heaven or hell in this world
since they're nothing but fantasies
created as a coping mechanism for weak
humans inosuke shouts that he doesn't
care if there's no hell because he can
just make one himself and tells noma not
to talk about his mother the demon sends
his freezing clouds at enosuke which he
blows away with beast's breathing as
kanye prepares to use another breath
style to attack him from behind doma
bats are away with one of his fans and
moves away azanoska yells at him to get
back down so they can continue fighting
he replies that he can't since akaza has
been defeated and he doesn't have time
to play anymore he uses his blood demon
art crystalline divine child to create
smaller clones of himself for enosuke
and kaneo to fight instead the clones
attack the demon's lair duo with doma's
techniques as the real doma starts to
walk away now at the exit dome thinks
about how a nosegame managed to avoid
breathing in the icy air from his
techniques and takes note of his sharp
senses saying that he will make sure to
remember him he spectates the battle for
a few seconds closely observing how they
each use their techniques so they'll be
able to kill them quickly the next time
they fight doma decides to create three
more clones and let them roam free
around the castle in order to kill the
rest of the demon slayers there he
overhears kaneo shouting to enosuke that
they have to hold their ground just a
little bit longer and wonders what this
could mean but then dismisses it and
begins to reach for the door handle
suddenly doma's face begins to melt he
drops to the floor one of his arms
snapping off and his crystal children
begin to crack and disintegrate as he
wonders what's happening enosuke asks if
it's a trap but kaneo having been
informed prior to the battle of
shinobu's plan to kill doma tells him
that it isn't and that the demon is
being melted by the poison shinobu had
in their body when he consumed her she
tells the nosegay to aim for his neck to
finish him off and in a panic doma plays
his final and most powerful card blood
demon art rime water lily bodhisattva
doma's icebody sativa statue slams his
hand down on the floor creating a small
earthquake that sends anosuke and kaneo
up into the air kanyo notes that his
technique lacks precision it is clearly
the demon's last effort to protect
himself with the little energy he had
left deciding to use her final form
flower brooding final form equinox
vermilion eye to try and break through
to him doma's statue grabs inosuke as
kanyo leaps towards the upper rank
hitting her blade against his neck she
is unable to cut it so winosuke on the
spot comes up with a new technique and
throws his blades at kaneo to give it
the extra strength needed to cut doma's
neck they succeed in beheading him and
the upper rank 2 and his statue begin to
disintegrate
as his head falls to the floor domo
thinks about how pathetic he must be to
have lost to a poisoner like shinobu
someone who didn't even have the
strength to kill a demon by cutting its
head he thinks to himself that he
shouldn't give up and he should try and
regenerate his head as akasa almost did
but soon comes to realize that it would
be futile and that he is going to die in
his final moments doma says that he is
not afraid of death or even frustrated
that he had lost and recalls his past as
a human and his inability to feel any
emotion now in the afterlife doma opens
his eyes to shinobu who is holding his
severed head in one hand she asks if
he's finally dead and says that she can
now rest in peace doma asks her if her
name is shinobu or connie and she says
that it doesn't really matter because he
makes her sick and she doesn't want him
to say her name anyway he ignores this
going on to compliment her for her
poisoning skills and expressed his
surprise at not noticing that it had
circulated through him before it was too
late and she smiles and explains that a
demon called tomio helped her make it
shinobu says that she is frustrated that
she couldn't kill him herself and the
fact that she can no longer help the
demon slayer's defeat muzan but she is
still satisfied with the result doma
gives her a look and shinobu asks what's
wrong to which the demon says that he
feels like his heart is beating and
wonders if he has fallen in love he
thinks aloud that if love really exists
heaven and hell must too and ashinobu if
she wants to go to hell together with
him but she tells him to piss off and
calls him a worthless bastard click on
this video where we explain the entire
story of muzan kibbutsuji don't be shy
click it